good morning or good afternoon depending
on which time zone you're in
uh first of all i want to start off by
saying thank you
uh for joining us today uh we are very
excited to present
to you a new product that luminex is
launching um in 2021
it is our next generation x-map
instrument
called the intelliflex so i'm going to
give you a brief overview
of luminex just to get started here from
a corporate standpoint
and then i'm going to pass it off to dr
sherry dunbar
who uh will go into more detail about
intelliflex
some unique applications we think um
that we'll see with the instrument and
then i will wrap up
so luminex was founded in 1995
by three brothers that
were sitting in a mexican restaurant and
they had
a novel idea about color-coding
microspheres
they literally drew up what they thought
was what's going to be the plan
on the back of a napkin and launch
luminex from there
so we we're we're headquartered in
austin
but through partnerships
uh with black science research companies
and with other
clinical companies we have grown into
growing through a global organization of
more than 1300 employees
so the reason that we have partners is
when luminex was
was first uh when it first came about
we had the technology we knew it was a
really cool
earth uh earth-shattering technology but
we didn't have the resources
to really build the assays that would
allow
the technology to spread globally so
what we did is we partnered with
i guess the life science partners and
also clinical diagnostic partners
for the largest partners that we have in
the life science world are millipore
bio-rad biotechnium thermo and using
this model
is what has allowed us to grow from a
very small company to where we are today
so just to give you a timeline of
where them they started and where we're
going so the first instrument which is
the lx100 which some of you may be
familiar with
actually shipped in 1997. and then from
there
we brought we branched out from just a
research market
into also a clinical diagnostic market
with the first test being
cystic fibrosis uh from there we've
launched
uh next-gen
x-map instruments and also through
acquisition we have also launched um
other platforms that are widely accepted
in the clinical
research sorry the clinical diagnostic
market uh you guys may have heard the
news
we were one of the first companies to
get a sars
kobe 2 molecular assay cleared
through the fda and then we also have a
sars kobe 2 serology s that has also
been
fda clear you can see on the far right
as we the the reason we're here today is
because we're going to discuss
in more detail the launch of the
intelliflex
so the current offering that uh that
luminex has
on the xmap technology are the lx200 and
the flexmap 3d
these are both flow-based instruments
that are able to
read the color-coded microspheres
that allows us to achieve multiplexing
or looking at multiple analytes
in a single well uh the 200 and flex map
one that are both flow based
they have different capabilities uh the
200 will
allow you to read up to 100 b regions
per well so that means that you could
look up to
100 analytes at the same time from a
single sample
and then the flex map was the next gen
of our x-men instrumentation
and it will actually allow you to
assay up to 500 different uh analytes in
the same time
the same well so you can see here a lot
of data can be generated from a single
run
using using both these instruments
so the reason we're here today is to go
into more detail and applications of the
intelliflex so the intelliflex is the
fourth gen
uh the fourth generation of our x-map
instruments
and when we when we were thinking about
building this instrument
we really wanted to make sure that we
were
you know meeting unmet needs in the
market so we did an extensive voice of
customer
um to make sure that you know
what we're going to build is going to be
what the customers actually need
so three of the the the three bullet
ports
three bullet points here just a few of
the uh
the capabilities of the of the flex
mapping and went into
the reasoning behind it we built it the
way we did
the most exciting thing about the about
the intelliflex
is it has a dual reporter channel versus
a single reporter channel
which sherry will go into more detail
with for different applications
that we see can be utilized by our
customers and also our partners
so now i'm going to pass it off to
sherry and she is going to
go into more detail about a teleplex
thank you josh and hello to everyone
i'm going to start by giving you a brief
overview of xmap
technology
first of all xmap is a proven technology
in the 25 years since our company
began there have been over 54 000 peer
review publications that use
xmap technology either through luminex
or through our partner products
in addition there's over 1300 ruo assays
that have been developed
and more than 105 10k clearances for
xmap technology
firstly anything that can be covalently
coupled to a bead
can be used to develop an x-map assay
for protein analysis
we can use all of the classic assay
formats such as capture sandwich
competitive and indirect or serology
to identify analytes to study protein
expression
immune response drug monitoring and many
others
the same technology can be used for
genomic analyses
through the coupling of a capture probe
onto the bead there are also multiple
assay chemistries that can be used from
direct hybridization to
primary extension and oligoligation and
the technology is capable of
discrimination to the single
nucleotide level it performs very well
for snip genotyping
micro rna analysis and it can also be
quantitative or
semi-quantitative with appropriate
standards and controls
the nucleic acid assay has been used for
applications such as copy number
variation
so how does xmap multiplexing compare to
other common platforms
well as compared to the singleplex
technology such as
elisa with xmap you will be running all
of your assays simultaneously in
solution
with a small reaction volume you will
use less sample
you will spend less time and less work
and less cost for reagents and
consumables
in addition you will generate more data
and really better data which i'm going
to explain to you further in a moment
as compared to planar arrays you will
have faster binding kinetics because all
of the beads are in suspension
and you have a very high surface to
volume ratio which can also provide
better sensitivity as an example
in order to analyze 43 targets from 27
samples
in triplicate you would need to perform
almost 3 500 single plex reactions
which would require 37 96 well plates
whereas on xmas technology you only need
one
luminex's partners have really taken the
technology to the next level
with over 300 assays as well as custom
assay capabilities available for many of
our partners
and various analysis software packages
that can be used to
analyze the data that's generated
in addition our kit finder app which is
available on the luminex website can
help you find a kit
for your analytes and your species of
interest
let's talk briefly about how the
detection works on our flow
analyzers the completed assay containing
the multiplexed beads is aspirated
into the sample cuvette in a rapidly
flowing fluid stream
hydrodynamic focusing confines the beads
to the center of the sheet fluid core
and sends the beads past the lasers one
at a time
each bead is excited with the red laser
to measure the unique combination of
dyes
inside the bead which identifies the
bead region
and hence the specific assay being
measured
the green laser excites and measures the
surface orange fluorescence to quantify
the amount of analyte that has been
bound
so now how are the data analyzed for
each reaction we typically measure
a minimum of 50 beads for each bead
color
or bead set that is in the reaction and
we determine the median
of fluorescence intensity measured for
those beads
we call this value the mfi so and unlike
an elisa where you are measuring the sum
of the signal in a well
each beat is measured as a replicate of
that reaction
and for each well we're essentially
measuring 50 replicates and reporting
the median
of those measurements and the median is
really the best statistic to use
because unlike the mean it cannot be
skewed by a few carryover events from a
previous well
i wanted to mention a recent publication
that describes how
xmap multiplexing technology was used in
immunogenicity study
to simultaneously screen and isotype
anti-drug antibodies for humera
as a model system the multiplexed assay
was developed and validated to meet the
fda recommended guidelines for
immunogenicity assessments first they
used biotinylated humira to enrich
chimera reactive anti-drug antibodies
from the samples
the humera enriched ada samples were
then added to the combined bead sets
and the standard assay steps were
performed first sample incubation
followed by washing and then the
reactions were incubated with
biotinylated humera
and the streptavidin phycoerythrin
reporter die
the captured ada on each bead set was
measured via the pe fluorescence
on a luminex flex map 3d instrument
so by applying the cut points that were
developed for both screening
and confirmation they were able to
simultaneously screen and do ada
isotoping
in a single reaction the results showed
that the multiplexed assays performed
comparably to industry standards
and the authors concluded that labs
should explore the use of multiplexing
immunogenicity assays
in order to characterize anti-drug
antibody responses quickly
with less repeat testing and reduce
sample handling
and so we have the citation for the
publication
available on this slide but in addition
we can follow up with you
and give you some resources if you want
to dig into this study
in a little bit more detail
so now the next part i want to introduce
you to our new kid
on the block the xmap intelliflex system
xmap intelliflex provides the same
multiplexing platform that you know and
trust
with enhanced features and an overall
better user experience
we all have two models the standard
model has much of the same features that
you're used to
on the flexmat 3d instrument such as
a 500 plugs a single green reporter
laser
both 96 and 384 well capability
but it also has an additional decade of
dynamic range
greater than or equal to 5.5 logs now
and with an integrated pc and a touch
screen it has a more compact footprint
that will fit better into today's
laboratory environment
as well as new hardware features that
make the system really easy to load and
unload
but also modular components inside the
hood which
allows for easy field service access
the second model the drse model has the
second reporter channel that we're very
excited about
this uses a violet laser and the new
channel has about four and a half logs
of dynamic range
to allow for basically two
reporter signals per reaction per
analyte
in addition this model also has a side
eject plate carrier to make it easy to
connect to laboratory automation systems
so let me tell you a little bit about
how the optics
work in this new intelliflex system on
the left
in the single reporter system we have
our avalanche photodiodes or the apd's
and our doublet discriminator dd for
bead classification through the red
laser
the green laser excites and sends the
reporter fluorescence
to the pmt to measure the reporter 1
emission
at about 565 to 585 nanometers
and it will also send reporter signal to
the extended dynamic
range or edr detector so that the
reporter signal can still be quantified
even if the pmt has reached saturation
on the right hand side in the dual
reporter model
we have an additional 405 nanometer
violet laser that excites the second
reporter die
and measures emission at about 421 to
441 nanometers
in a second pmt
so now let me share with you some
intelliflex performance data
this data was kindly provided by our
partner therma fisher
and in this study they ran the
procardaplex 45
plex panel for human cytokines and what
they're showing us here is the results
for il-8
you can see on the left-hand side that
when the standard curves on intelliflex
were compared to the luminex 200 and
flex map 3d
instruments at all of the possible
different calibration
settings the results were virtually
identical
and then if you look on the right at the
results for a variety of different
samples
the results were also very similar to
that that can be achieved on the current
instruments
so this demonstrates what we call
backward compatibility and this is going
to be important for those of you who are
all you
already using an x-map instrument you
will have the option of seeing the
results you're used to
as well as trying some of the new data
analysis options
now let's talk about the new second
reporter channel
this data is from some work that we did
to evaluate
the dual reporter functionality for
simultaneously measuring igm
and igg antibodies specific to sars cov2
on the left panel we used luminex's sars
cov2 multi-antigen kit
with some known samples and evaluated
the reporter signal in each channel run
either separately or together in dual
reporter mode
and what you can see is that we can
measure the two different isotypes
captured onto the
same bead with the two reporters and
there is no impact to the signal when
they are together
in the same reaction on the right is
some work done
using a three flex serological assay
also for stars cov2
that in this case ace2 was added as a
competitor
to serve as a surrogate marker for
neutralizing antibody response
the blue cells show the reported 2
signal response and the orange
cells show the reporter one response and
so you can see as we titrate through the
different uh
samples you're seeing in dose response
increase
in signal and then uh if you look at the
green highlighted cells
this is showing wells where we got
a greater than or equal to 30 percent
binding inhibition
with the addition of the ace ii so we
think that the dual reporter is going to
be really useful for these types of
serological and
neutralizing antibody applications with
both reporter channels you're
essentially doubling the data that you
can get per reaction
by being able to measure both igm and
igg
or any two isotypes together at the same
time
so here's an example of nucleic acid
assays that were run
in the dual reporter mode on the left
hand side we had a two plex assay for
two different oligonucleotide targets
each one was labeled with a different
reporter die and what you can see here
is that when we have both targets and
both reporters present in the same
reaction at the same time
the signal is equivalent to what we see
when we only have one target and one
reporter present
so this is actually a first step an
important first step
to show the functionality of the two
reporter system
and since we really saw no interference
we were pretty pleased with the results
now finally we wanted to have another
model system that would look at
the performance when we actually have
both reporters on the same molecule
captured onto the same bead so here on
the right we have a dna target
that has been dual labeled with the two
reporter dyes
one die is on the five prime end of the
target and one is on the three prime end
thus we have a single analyte molecule
that's dual labeled and again we see no
impact on the performance in the dual
reporter system as compared to when we
have only
one die or the other so we feel pretty
confident in the performance of the dual
reporter
and we're pretty excited about the
usefulness that we think this is going
to provide
as a final example which is shown
conceptually here
is a dual reporter assay that we think
would be really relevant in pharmacology
and drug discovery
with the dual reporter system you could
simultaneously measure
a free versus a bound drug if you have
specific antibodies
that recognize the free form of the drug
and the bound form of the drug
you could label them with different
reporters and measure them
simultaneously
although not drawn here you might
envision that the antibody specific for
the free drug would actually bind to
both forms
depending on the location of the epitope
but then you would be able to measure
the bound
form as a percentage of the total that
was present in the sample
so we think this is a really kind of
creative
and interesting possible application
for the dual reporter system and we're
really excited to see somebody
try it out and let us know how it works
so now before we finish up
i would like to pass the presentation
back over to josh for some closing
remarks
thank you so the next slide
is where i want to circle back to talk a
little bit more about uh when sherry
was discussing the ada and isotyping in
the in the same well
uh currently this is not being done at
least as far as i know
by any other technology so either you do
just the ada or then you do the
isotaping isotype them separately
and then you're either typing each one
separately so that could be multiple
eliza's
um or multiple other types of of acid
that you're doing
with this study that was done you can
now
combine both the ada and the isotoping
into a single well which
obviously is going to reduce workflow
reduce sample needed
and reduce time to answers so uh
luminex is launching what we're calling
the xmap ada
study starter pack where we provide the
beads coupling kits and
all the ancillary agents that are needed
to complete the
to build the assay while these assays
are custom
because each capture molecule is going
to be different
the great thing is we have both field
application scientists
that are available to assist in
developing these types of assets for you
and then we also have
um our custom asset development lab
based in austin called the explore lab
so we really like this this is going to
you know this offering is going to
allow for you to get your answers in a
much faster
and more cost effective manner so if you
have any questions about that
please feel free to reach out to me or
to share
so that's our last slide this one ended
with a thank you
thank you sherry for that presentation
very informative
um as i said before we're very excited
about the intelliflex you can see
the applications that we've already
shown that that are
that are available on the new instrument
and then
also some applications that are
conceptually
relevant and we feel like you know this
is really going to
assist in your drug development moving
forward so thanks again
and we look forward to fielding any
questions that you may have